the 19 year old nursing student accused
of killing one person and wounding three
others at a synagogue is now charged
with a hate crime uh-huh vada Poway near
San Diego held a funeral yesterday for
the 60 year-old woman who died
protecting her Rabbi David beg no
attended this service and he's in San
Diego David good morning John good
morning we're at the courthouse here in
downtown San Diego because the suspect
is going to be arraigned here later
today you spoke about that memorial
service we were there yesterday at the
request of the family who wanted the
media inside and we noticed that his
mourners were walking in they were
passing through doors that are still
marked with bullet holes mourners packed
the Habad of Holloway Monday to
celebrate the life of Laurie kay there
were so many people not everyone could
get in Laurie's daughter Hannah
remembered her mom as a colorful woman
she chose to wear her mom's pink dress
my best friend the greatest advocate the
FBI now confirms they were warned about
the attack just minutes before it
happened but didn't have enough time or
information to stop it we spoke to a man
who says he alerted the FBI after seeing
the shooters supposed anti-semitic
manifesto on the online forum the
warning in a statement the family of
suspected gunman John artist disavowed
his actions saying how our son was
attracted to such darkness is a
terrifying mystery to us to our great
shame he is now part of the history of
evil that has been perpetrated on Jewish
people for centuries
rabbi yes Roy al goldstein was one of
three injured in the shooting this was
an attack on humanity and we need to
recognize that we need to change
something we need to do something
radically different because the status
quo is not working you know this gunman
is also accused of setting fire at a
mosque last
in this area his family says they do not
plan to hire a defense attorney for him
which means a public defender will
probably represent him and John I have
to tell you at the memorial service
yesterday the the eulogy given by
Laurie's daughter moved everyone in the
room and at one point she said to the
crowd my mother would have forgiven her
killer Wow
David that's very powerful thank you
very much David